[Música]
vamos ahora a hablar de revista de
prensa por supuesto con rosa pérez más
de euros a bienvenida muy buena mañana
de miércoles vamos a abrir entonces esta
revista de prensa con la actualización
del tema con el que abrimos ayer es que
finalmente rosa el vuelo destinado a
ruanda con demandantes de asilo en el
reino unido se quedó en la tierra es
decir eso fue cancelado por la decisión
de un tribunal europeo de los derechos
humanos como labor de entonces esto la
prensa británica buenos días raúl pues
al contrario de lo que veíamos ayer que
es que pues la mayoría de periódicos
británicos no daban un espacio en
portada a este vuelo que ayer tenía que
despegar hoy sí que destacan que
finalmente como bien decías se quedó en
tierra eso sí recordar que el gobierno
británico y había pagado el medio millón
de libras que costaba pues en fletar
este avión pero vamos a ver cómo lo
destacan pues los medios que hemos
seleccionado por un lado the gardian
dice caos mientras el primer vuelo a
ruanda fue cancelado por la justicia y
señala que tras una deliberación de 11
horas el tribunal europeo de derechos y
acabó cancelando los siete casos porque
recordemos que eran siete demandantes de
asilo los que iban a ser trasladados
forzosamente a ruanda en este pues
primer avión de esta política británica
impulsada por el gobierno de boris
johnson que pretende pues mandar a
ruanda a los solicitantes de asilo del
reino unido dice que de hecho los fallos
del tribunal europeo de los derechos
humanos se basaron en que en un primer
lugar este tribunal suspendió el
traslado forzoso de un iraquí de 54 años
al que el 27 de mayo según un informe
médico se declaró que había sido
sometido a torturas y en base a esta
primera suspensión desde el traslado de
este hombre iraquí acabó fallando el
tribunal pues en suspender los otros
seis casos dice the gardian la decisión
es un golpe significante y avergonzante
para boris johnson y su secretaria de
interior brit y patel quienes
prometieron mandar a miles de
solicitantes de asilo a ruanda pretty
pater por su lado dice que el gobierno
está decepcionado y que el tribunal no y
hacer lo correcto y recordar lo que
decíamos que esto esta decisión fue un
estudio caso por caso ayer pero que en
julio el tribunal analizará en la
conjunto de la ley y recordar raúl
porque siempre esto genera un poco de
confusión el tribunal europeo de
derechos humanos también llamado
tribunal de estrasburgo por la ciudad
francesa donde está basado es un
tribunal en el que cualquier persona que
se sienta víctima de una vulneración de
los derechos humanos bajo jurisdicción
de un país del consejo de europa pues
puede acudir recordemos que el reino
unido- forma parte del consejo de europa
porque el consejo de europa no es una
institución de la unión europea no es
una de las instituciones de bruselas
aunque por su nombre es fácil
confundirlo con el consejo europeo o el
consejo de la unión europea y eso ha
pasa a pesar de que después de el break
si del reino unido no forma parte ya de
la unión europea si continúa formando
parte del consejo de europa pero boris
johnson precisamente dijo que este
tribunal que se basa en la convención
europea de derechos humanos pues que al
final acaba interfiriendo con la
soberanía del reino unido- y que se
planteaba incluso pues esa de esta
convención vamos a ver cómo termina todo
esto por otro lado el daily telegraph
dice deportaciones a ruanda bloqueadas
por jefes europeos ya hemos explicado
por qué europeos de independent que era
el medio que ayer sí destacaba importada
estas expulsiones dice el vuelo a ruanda
se queda en tierra para proteger los
derechos humanos y the times dice jueces
europeos bloquean las deportaciones a
ruanda y como señalábamos ayer
deportaciones es una forma de decirlo
porque las deportaciones hacen
referencia a las devoluciones al país de
origen de un extranjero y en este caso
pues se manda a ruanda solicitantes de
asilo que no son ruandeses y también
pues al lado vemos la foto de este
deporte cricket es muy popular en región
y también en su colonia india y en
pakistán también efectivamente eso lo
comentábamos con el mars en deporte
quizás pues lo pueden mencionar el
cricket a este deporte que para nosotros
es tan tan lejano así desde la excolonia
y me dije colonia pero excolonia pues ya
obviamente no es vamos ahora como peter
brooks en the times que hace una crítica
sátira de este tema rosa exacto vemos
este este avión o en ruanda airlines
lleno del gobierno británico pues vemos
a boris johnson encabezando esta lista
está lista este grupo de expulsados
junto a la secretaria de exteriores
listas la encargada de esta política
junto a pretty pater la de interior y
otros miembros del ejecutivo británico y
dice esta caricatura la única forma
moral de llenar vuelos sólo de ida hacia
fuera del país no a expulsar un poco el
gobierno y recordemos que según the
times una información que no ha sido
digamos confirmada por la casa real
británica incluso el príncipe carlos
habría calificado esta política esta
iniciativa de espantosa una política que
como decíamos todavía no se ha ejecutado
bueno y veremos al final si acaba pues
siendo una realidad bueno rosa
muchísimas gracias entonces por esta
revista de prensa del día de hoy ahí
pues vemos esa crítica satírica a un
gobierno también escandaloso como ha
sido el de boris johnson rosa muchísimas
gracias entonces por toda la información
nos vemos con más de revista de prensa
pasamos a saludar a nuestro primer
invitado el día precisamente para
ampliar ese tema